and Senate Intelligence Committee is
having its own heated debate over the
FISA memo joining us now for reaction on
the Republican side is Senator Jim
Lankford of Oklahoma a member of that
committee senator you heard congressman
Garamendi there he hadn't read the memo
he's concerned about releasing the memo
he didn't want to read it because then
he couldn't talk about it I didn't quite
follow that but nevertheless we're glad
that he came on your view on on this
situation now because the Democrats are
saying Republicans now are anti FBI and
poisoning the whole kit and kaboodle
with their integrity and character of
the agents let me just say there are
35,000 employees in the FBI and there's
some fantastic people that work all
around the country they keep us safe on
terrorism they keep us safe from gang
violence they work exceptionally hard in
cybersecurity there's some fantastic
folks but he's very clear there are also
some people that were in headquarters
that we have text messages up back and
forth they worked in the Hillary Clinton
email scandal and then were hired on to
do the Trump investigation by the
Special Counsel that clearly had biases
against President Trump and we're trying
to support Hillary Clinton in the in the
campaign that there's no question about
that so this is not a challenge the
35,000 hard-working men and women
keeping us safe in the FBI this is a
challenge to probably people they are
frustrated with that are in headquarters
that are not following basic FBI code
and procedures and Senator did it bother
you to find out yesterday that the
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe had it
was one of a few people who knew that
there were thousands of those Hillary
emails as early as September 28th of
2016 and then the Congress wasn't told
about that into a full month later do
you have concerns about that given your
oversight responsibilities I do have
concerns and I do sit on the
Intelligence Committee and on the
Homeland Security Committee both them
having oversight there for the basic
functions of our security and our
intelligence that is very serious
anytime you get evidence and you sit on
that evidence for a long period of time
and then once it's exposed in Jim Comey
know about it then they frantically went
through it in a couple of days to be
able to work through that that's
interesting to see them during the heat
of the election to sit on additional
information that
Anthony Weiner's from computer that his
wife was sending him information that
did include some of this email traffic
that was supposed to be secured traffic
but then she's also forwarding on to her
husband's unsecured computer as well
that's a big concern and should have
been a big concern and by the way
Senator Jim Comey was he's quite the
tweeter lately and he tweeted this
earlier today he said all should
appreciate the FBI speaking up I wish
more of our leaders would but take heart
American history shows that in the long
run weasels and Liars never hold the
field so long as good people stand up
not a lot of schools or streets named
for Joe McCarthy your reaction to that
well it's a kind of a little stunning
reaction clearly FBI if they have a bad
actor there that is a biased person then
that person needs to be cleared as well
again we've got 35,000 great folks that
are serving we need to continue to honor
their service as well and it was
interesting our to comment that the
congressman had made before saying
nothing has been done to prepare for
that that is absolutely not true
I personally spoken with Kirsten Nilson
who's the new head of DHS I'd spoken to
now the for the president was led when
he led it they have actively engaged in
trying to protect our elections DHS has
been very engaged with our states
they're working very hard to make sure
that there are additional protections
coming in for the next election so that
has already begun all right senator
thanks so much